well if you are an unemployment claimant
that had your bank account closed we
have an update for you tonight
joe mohler joins us live some now joe
are saying they are seeing some progress
in hopefully getting accounts reopened
after an email this week joe
yeah well some of those unemployment
claimants who had their bank of america
unemployment account
close or frozen received an email this
week and some were pretty skeptical
on clicking those emails but we did get
in contact with theater who says this is
part of the process
it's been since the beginning of
december
like many others leandria vaughan's
unemployment bank of america account
was closed after she reported a
fraudulent transaction i received an
email
showing that it was coming from dieter
um and it was
a link to the verify me through id
me that email came in thursday and it
looked like this
i didn't want to press any links or push
anything because i didn't know if it for
sure came from dieter
dieter confirmed with us friday they do
use id me
we got in contact with id me as well
they explained in a statement
id me significantly speeds up the
identity verification process allowing
individuals to obtain their benefits
faster and with a much reduced risk of
fraud
most individuals complete the process in
just a few minutes
all the bills are piling up i'm afraid
i'm going to lose my
car lose via gracia has been waiting
eight weeks
she received a call from a deter fraud
investigator this week
she said she will be getting paper
checks for the week she was without pay
next week she'll find out if her account
is reopened the next
payment will be deposited in the
debit card so from here on out
now both of those claimants there hope
this does mean that their account is
reopened now the other issue that
people are going to have to deal with
now is getting that money that was
stolen out of their accounts
back bank of america says those
investigations are continuing and they
will be in contact with claimants
as soon as their claim has a
determination reporting live in las
vegas joe mohler 8 news now